Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Some people say that the most boring thing
is watching paint dry. They have clearly not
seen this amazing research work, that makes
it possible to simulate the entire process
of painting on a canvas.
We have covered plenty of papers in fluid
simulations, and this is no exception - I
admit that I am completely addicted and just
can't help it. Maybe I should seek professional
assistance.
So, as there is a lot of progress in simulating
the motion of fluids, and paint is a fluid,
then why not simulate the process of painting
on a canvas?
The simulations with this technique are so
detailed that even the bristle interactions
are taken into consideration, therefore one
can capture artistic brush stroke effects
like stabbing. Stabbing, despite the horrifying
name, basically means shoving the brush into
the canvas and rotating it around to get cool effect.
The fluid simulation part includes paint adhesion
and is so detailed that it can capture the
well-known impasto style where paint is applied
to the canvas in such large chunks, they are
so thick that one can see all the strokes
that have been made. And all this is done
in real-time. Amazing results.
Traditional techniques cannot even come close
to simulating such sophisticated effects.
As it happened many times before in computer
graphics: just put such a powerful algorithm
into the hands of great artists and enjoy
the majestic creations they give birth to.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!